one argument that we make is that we
could all benefit a little bit from
thinking more like children okay now you
could say well we're bi I look first of
all everybody's biased in a lot of ways
and we have our set of biases too it may
be that we embrace the idea in this book
of thinking like children cuz we're kind
of you know childlike we have kind of
obvious observations sometimes or
observations that strike people as
obvious we um we ask a lot of questions
that are not considered you know the
kind of questions that people ask in
good company or smart company but one of
the most powerful pieces of thinking
like a child that we argue is thinking
small so I realize that this runs
exactly counter to the philosophy of the
arena in which I'm pier appearing which
is thinking big big thing but our
argument is this big problems are by
their nature really hard to solve for a
variety of reasons one is they're large
and therefore they include a lot of
people and therefore they include a lot
of crossed and often mangled and
perverse incentives but also a big
problem when you think about a big
problem like the education where
education reform you're dealing with an
institution or a set of institutions
that have gotten to where they've gotten
through this many many years of
calcification and also accidents of
history what I mean by that is things
have gotten to the way they've gotten
because of a lot of things that a few
people did many many years ago and
traditions were carried on and now to
suddenly change that would mean changing
the entire stream of the way that this
institution is functioned for many years
therefore attacking any big problem is
bound to be really hard and the danger
is you spend a lot of resources time
money manpower optimism which is perhaps
one of our most precious resources
attacking a problem that you can't make
any headway on so I mean you know the
history is littered with brilliant
people who have attacked large problems
in the past
half century or century among them
famine among them poverty and most
recently I think education reform a
healthy diet and so on so these are all
really big problems so our argument is
you know what there's a lot of people
out there thinking big maybe some of
them will be successful probably not so
many honestly it's very very hard our
argument is you know what let the people
who are going to try to think big solve
big problems
let them go there's enough people doing
that why don't you just try to think
small why don't you try to find one
piece of the problem that you can
identify and peel it off and try to
solve that problem or answer that
question so a lot of reasons why it's
better to do that it's easier to
satisfactorily answer a small question
or solve a big problem because you can
get the data you can understand the
incentives it's just inherently much
less complicated if you can come up with
a solution to a small problem there's a
much better chance you'll actually be
able to get it done a lot of people feel
like come up with the answers to big
problems but then you need to get all
the political and capital will to do it
and that can be much harder than
actually solving the problem so if you
can peel off a small piece of a problem
and then someone else peels off another
small piece and you add them up you're
constantly you know working toward a
better place so I'll give you an example
if you think about let's say education
reform even that very phrase is kind of
weighted or biased toward the
supply-side the schools it's basically
saying that oh all the kids and the
families were sending their kids to
school they're all doing exactly the
right thing but education needs to be
reformed because plainly the schools and
teachers and principals they're the bad
people so that's kind of an assumption
already about where the problem should
be solved so you think you know people
have been talking about the many many
inputs that go into education class size
technology in the classroom resources
spent curricula the way that curricular
taught and so on so you know what if you
say instead you know well that's all
those are big parts of the education
puzzle and they can all be attacked in
some way what if however what if we
think about instead of the education
side what if you think about the stew
side what if you think about the kids
who are showing up from school
and what if you can look at areas in
which they're not doing well and maybe
try to learn something from that and
gather some data and figure it out so I
could offer two examples about this one
is a pilot program that was built here
in New York City that was called called
school of one and what school of one did
it basically tried an entirely different
model for each kid let's say in a math
class each kid would come into math
class on a given day and have the option
of learning that day's lesson or
whatever lesson in a number of different
formats in other words it might be
sitting in a room with a teacher and a
bunch of other kids and getting group
instruction it might be peer learning
with other kids might be virtual
tutoring might be doing a computer game
in other words you offer all these
different options for each kid to try to
learn the same material then at the end
of each day each kid gets tested on how
well they did on that lesson and then
you can learn what each kid how each kid
best learn what form of teaching best
learn then you have a very nice
algorithm that overnight computes the
score of each kid with each kind of
teaching and in the morning each kid now
comes in with a sort of playlist to
determine what I'm going to do today in
what format of learning and what I'm
going to tackle so that's to me
a really neat idea in which technology
and a smart way of thinking about the
demand side of Education the students
can change the way you can think about
learning generally here's an even
simpler one than that and even smaller
than that it turns out that if you look
at the poorest learners in schools I
think pretty much anywhere but in the US
and in a much poorer countries as well
you can notice that often a bunch of
them have something in common which is
they have bad eyesight so as ridiculous
as this seems to be talking about the
21st century you know who doesn't wear
glasses now I mean an estimated 1
million people in America wear glasses
that have no prescriptions in them just
because they want to look like me
okay so LeBron Jay
half of the NBA now goes to put on their
fake glasses after a game because it's
just become a thing right so you would
think that the stigma of glasses is dead
but it's not and in some places it's
really not dead so some scholars some
researchers went to a relatively poor
rural province in China and they wanted
to know how big a deal is poor eyesight
for education generally in other words
is poor vision depressing classroom
scores and what they did is they found
out that a tiny a pitiful e tiny
fraction of the students in this one
region who needed glasses were wearing
them almost none and there was a stigma
and there were beliefs that wearing
glasses in childhood would have a bad
effect later in life and so on some of
which may have logic to them some of
which may not so they didn't experiment
these economists did and they said what
if we take all these students who need
glasses and we'll divide them up make an
experiment we'll have a control group
the kids half the kids keep going like
they were before they don't get glasses
the other half we give them glasses
fifteen dollar glasses I think it was
funded by the World Bank much cheaper
than all new computers new curriculums
on $15 pair of glasses they gave to the
one set of kids then after a year they
measured their education their test
scores against the kids who hadn't
gotten the glasses and it turns out that
having glasses is a really big deal in
school surprise surprise right tiny
problem incredibly obvious solution
we're thinking like a child you know
sometimes we shy away from obvious ideas
because we think oh that's not
sophisticated enough not smart enough
here however was a bunch of low-hanging
through a bunch of kids who needed
glasses the minute they got them they
started doing much much better in school
and that to me is the beauty of thinking
small you find a problem that you can
actually figure out instead of a pining
about it and guessing about it for years
and years come up with a solution that's
actually doable and in this case
incredibly cheap and happy ending it
works not every solution will be so easy
or so cheap or they won't always work
but I think you can see why we think at
least at thinking
small can have a huge benefit